The one who is the true light, who gives light
to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
But who was this light?
He was and is God with us?
Well, it's great to see you church as we inch closer
to Christmas, uh, kids just 10 more sleeps.
So just know that's coming soon.
Uh, but it is great to be together. My name is John.
If I haven't met you yet, I'm one of the pastors here.
I get to preach most of the time. It's an honor to do that.
Uh, we'd love to meet you.
If you are new, please come say hello
to us up here at the front afterwards
or at the new here area out there in the lobby.
Uh, but today we're continuing celebrating Christmas
as leading up to that this series.
We're calling God with us,
that word e Emmanuel in the Bible.
As we lead up to the celebration of
that in full on Christmas Eve, we're building up to it
as we go, which by the way, lemme remind you quickly
about Christmas Eve.
It's coming up on next Tuesday, the 24th.
Of course, it's three services here on that day,
2, 3 30 and five o'clock.
Uh, if you, generally the two o'clock's the most attended.
So if you can go towards the last two, that would be great.
Uh, but just so you know, that's coming up also no community
groups the next two Sundays.
So just as you prepare to come those Sundays, uh, just know
that's on the website
as well if you need to find it in the future.
But what we began last Sunday as we, uh, began this journey,
it was a journey through John chapter one.
And so if you don't have it already open, let me invite you
to take your copy of God's word and turn there with me.
John chapter one will also be in there next week.
So leave a bookmark there to finish this little section.
We kicked it off with verses one through five.
That was the introduction of John one,
where we dug deep theologically into what that word means.
The word that it talks about
and who it was, it was God, the Son, Jesus.
And so that he came
to give us life was the whole point of that last week.
Well, today we're gonna continue in verses six through 13
by looking at how Emmanuel God with us, how he brings
light this time.
Which by the way, if you haven't noticed,
we got new lights this week in the room.
So, uh, that's part of adjusting, learning, all of that.
We don't have heat, but we got new lights. So there you go.
Alright. Uh, as we get into it today, I was, I was walking
through my bedroom at some point early
morning this week sometime.
And just this thought flash into my head
and it relates really well to
what we're gonna talk about today.
And so I want you to start
by just thinking about your bedroom.
So you, you've got it in your head, right?
Like this is your Wait, is that not your bed? No. Okay.
Um, anyway, maybe it's more like this. Okay.
This is probably more likely what it is. Okay.
Well just think about your bedroom, right?
You, you know, whether it's that or something else.
Maybe it is your first picture. Okay, fine.
But whatever your bedroom looks like,
you know what it is, right?
So you've got it in your head
and you know it really where, where the, the desk is
that the, the chairs in the corner,
the Legos are scattered on the floor over here.
Clothes are in the watered up in the, like,
you know your room as you think about it in your head.
Here's what I came to realize though as I was walking
through my room.
It it, I walk a whole lot faster
through my room when the light's on compared
to when it's dark, right?
And you're like, of course. But
just think about that for a second.
I know my room really well. You know your room really well.
Like you could even picture it and place it in your head.
But when the light's off, you still walk slower
because you're not real sure how far away
that thing you're gonna stub your toe on actually is.
So you end up walking through your room
kinda like a zombie in some way.
Like you just sort of through trying to feel
where you know the desk is.
But you can't walk like you do when you walk through it
with the light on.
Now it's not an exact one-to-one correlation of course,
but what we get from John one six
through 13 is a similar idea
that not only does God bring life, this God
with us Emmanuel idea brings light
and light that overcomes the darkness
both in the world and in our lives.
So take a look at verses six through 13 with me.
Now follow along as I read this with that idea.
Verse six. There was a man sent from God
whose name was John.
He came as a witness to bear witness about the light
that all might believe through him.
He was not the light
but came to bear witness about the light,
the true light which gives light
to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
Yet the world did not know him.
He came to his own and his own people did not receive him.
But to all who did receive him, who believed in his name,
he gave the right to become children of God
who were born not of blood, nor of the will of the flesh,
nor of the will of man, but born of God.
Lord, thank you for this word.
Thank you that you have inspired 2000 years ago, John
to write this so
that we would know you better even today.
But Holy Spirit, we need you to illuminate this,
to give us understanding
and an application to know what you want of us from us,
for us, for your glory.
So help us today to see it
and know all of that with your eyes in our hearts
to see and understand it in Jesus' name.
Amen. So last week we had
to figure out who the word was.
Well this week we gotta figure out who this light is.
'cause the light seems to be acting.
And so we gotta know who that is.
And so specifically we know this light
was bringing salvation.
So the only one who can save is God himself.
And so we know already the light is associated
with is God,
which is why we capitalize the word light on your notes
because we're talking about something more
than just physical lights.
We're talking about the light.
'cause here what it's referring to is God the Son
that Messiah, that God
with us figure the word from last week.
Now is the light in this section. Jesus the Messiah.
So what verses one through five is it,
it showed us this ancient story of the origin of the word,
which we know there was no origin.
He always existed but, but that was the ancient story.
Now this section is the buildup to
that light giving savior showing up on the scene
crosses over a little bit to actually being here.
But what you see right away is the beginnings of
what we know as the Christmas story,
which we find in Luke two, Matthew one.
You find that elsewhere.
But, but what we know as the traditional major scene, all
that stuff, here's why it happened
and here's the buildup to it, which is first what God did
by sending witnesses about the light.
That's what we see here right away is that God sent
witnesses about the light to begin with.
This was coming. He needed to send a witness to declare it.
And so in first six we see the Apostle John
who's writing this, describe
the ministry of John the Baptist.
Now you knew those were different guys, right?
There's more than one John in the Bible.
John the Baptist, John the Apostle who wrote this,
John the Apostle, one of the disciples of Jesus, the 12,
like John the Apostle wrote this account of Jesus
and he's referring to John the Baptist
who was this eccentric guy
who ate locusts and honey in the desert.
Okay? So those are different people.
But John the Baptist was not somebody who'd just gone mad
and ended up in the wilderness.
No. He was in fact a fulfillment
of the prophecies from 400 years earlier in Malachi three
and 700 years earlier in Isaiah chapter 40.
Both of those said
that a figure like the Old Testament prophet Elijah,
was coming before the Messiah showed up.
Somebody like Elijah was gonna show up on the scene
that all would believe, that all would hear
and understand that's the point that that they needed
to repent and prepare the way for the Messiah to come.
So they're predicting 700, 400 years earlier
somebody like Elijah,
and that's what John the Baptist came to do.
Verses six through eight again,
there was a man sent from God.
That word sent is like an envoy, an ambassador
between one to another, sent from God whose name was John.
He came as a witness to bear witness about the light
that all might believe through him.
He was not the light, but he came
to bear witness about the light.
His job it says was to point to the savior, which he did.
He beared witness about the light so that all might believe
through the light and through his gospel.
That's what he came to do.
So what we see is God sent witnesses about the light first.
Specifically he sent John the Baptist.
So what this absolutely clearly says, he sent a witness,
specifically John the Baptist, to prepare the way
for the Messiah to show up on the scene.
So that's what it says.
But when we try to play to play that out, specifically today
to us, what do we learn?
How do we apply this in some way?
Well, we learn that God has sent you
and me just as much
to be witnesses about the light of Christ.
But it was generally so he spent John the Baptist
specifically, but he sent you
and me generally since none
of us are sitting here 2000 years ago, preparing the way
for the Messiah to come the first time.
That was John's job For us though, it's a general sense
of witnessing about this light because think about it.
Aren't we doing something very similar to
what John was called to do, what he was sent
to do originally?
There's a lot of similarities.
Like we talk about the birth of Christ in
Christmas season 2000 years ago.
In Bethlehem, we talk about it as if it's the first advent
you maybe heard of this season called advent.
What does that word mean? Advent means appearing.
And so when Jesus showed up 2000 years ago on the scene,
it was his first appearing.
Well, in a way, don't you know
that there's a second advent coming.
There's a second appearing of Jesus coming.
He's gonna return Acts one says just like he left when he
ascended into the clouds and the clouds hit him from sight.
As the apostles watched that happen, it says
explicitly angels told him he's coming back just
the same way that he left.
So he's going to be visible again from the clouds down
to the new heavens
and new earth someday a second advent.
And so in that sense, we are all sent
by God to be witnesses about the light.
John said, Hey, the light's showing up, the light's coming.
I'm pointing you to the light, the true light
that's coming soon.
We are witnesses about the true light who's coming
soon in a similar way.
Why? So that all may believe through him.
That's what John was doing.
He wanted all to believe through him.
We aren't the light either,
but we are witnesses about the light so that all may believe
that's what we want.
Right? And think about what a witness does.
Hopefully none of you have been in a situation like the
picture shows, but what does a witness do
in a situation like that?
A witness just tells what they know, what they've seen,
what they've heard, what
they've felt, what they've experienced.
That's all it is. You're not arguing anything.
You're just stating the facts of what you know
about the case at hand.
That's what a witness does. It's all John did.
What did John do? John just stood there in the wilderness.
People came to him.
He reminded them of the prophecies,
all the Old Testament that they knew.
He reminded them of those truths.
And then he pointed them to the truth of
who this Messiah was going to be
and what they needed to do in their hearts
to repent and believe.
That's all it was. Listen,
that's all we're supposed to do as well.
That's our job. Just as much to just declare
who he is, declare what he's done, declare
how he has saved us, declare how he has sustained us.
That's all we're doing. We're just witnesses about the light
that's changed us, that brought us out
of darkness into his marvelous light.
That's all similar to what John did.
And so we declare it.
But then also along with that, we live out a life
that reflects that light to others.
Just listen to Jesus how he put it
in Matthew chapter five, verses 14 through 16.
Now remember, we aren't the light,
we're witnesses about the light,
but you are the light of the world.
Jesus says So he, wait a second, we're not the light,
but he says, now you are the light of the world.
Okay? So we will talk about that in a second.
But he says, you are the light of the world.
A city set on a hill cannot be hidden,
nor do people light a lamp and put it under a basket,
but but on a stand.
And it gives light to all in the house. In the same way.
Let your light shine
before others so that they may see your good works
and give glory to your father who is in heaven.
So what it says is that no, we're not the true light.
But think about this, just like the moon that was a bright
full moon last night, right?
Just like the moon has no light in itself.
The only way it shines is by reflecting the light
of the sun to us.
Same way we are not light in ourselves,
but the true light inside of us shines brightly so
that all may believe, all may glorify
our Father who is in heaven.
The true light has come.
And what we do as we do that, hear me as we do that,
as we speak witness about who he is
and what he's done as we live lives that reflect his light.
Watch what happens. We are preparing the way
for the Messiah to come again.
The second advent's coming.
We are witnessing about the light, preparing the way
for the light, praying, working, witnessing
that all might believe through him.
You see the parallels here, but here's what can happen.
We can feel a lot of pressure with that.
Like that's overwhelm. Okay, well man,
we gotta be witnesses about the light.
But I'm not really a great witness of that. I'm not perfect.
Okay? Well here's the beauty of this.
Here's the the grace.
It's not based on how well we do at that.
It wasn't based on John's ability
to speak well enough
to baptize well enough to do all the he.
It wasn't based on that
because thankfully it wasn't just how well we witnessed
or how well he witnessed about the light.
Thankfully God sent the true light himself.
We don't just have to be a great example.
We don't have to be all of this perfect
reflection to the world.
Like we don't have to be that
because God sent the true light himself.
Look again at verse nine.
The true light which gives light
to everyone was coming into the world,
Like to a world walking around in a pitch black bedroom.
The light has come. The light himself came.
And we learned so much about this light.
Like last week we learned about the word.
What is his character? Who is he?
What does he do This week we learn about this light.
What do we learn about him? Well look just back into
what we looked at last week verses four
and five real quick about the word in
him was life.
That's physical, spiritual, emotional life.
And the life was the light of men.
The light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it.
So the eternal word here equated
with the true light of the world.
That figure that messiah, the giver of life.
What we learned from him is that when he came,
the darkness lost to him.
Do you see it in verse five?
The darkness has not overcome it. The darkness lost to him.
The darkness lost. This concept of darkness.
This is all over scripture.
If you would do a word study on darkness, just like going
to word uh, in the Bible software, online search,
whatever it is, and you search the word darkness
or dark in scripture, it's everywhere.
And what it refers to is evil or sin
or especially death.
I think all of that is included here.
When I say the darkness lost to light, lost
to the Messiah, all of that is included.
Just hear this. Think of Jesus saying it in John 1633.
He says in me, you may have peace in the world,
you'll have tribulation.
But take heart, I have overcome the world.
Like he's talking about all the evil that pervades
around us in the world.
Jesus says, hold up. It's gonna cause you trouble.
I've overcome it.
The darkness, evil lost to him.
Or think of Colossians two.
Jesus forgives our sins by canceling the record of debt
that stood against us with its legal demands.
This he set aside, nailing it to the cross.
He disarmed the rulers and authorities
and put them to open shame by triumphing over them in him.
That's victory language, right? The darkness lost to him.
The darkness of sin lost to him.
In fact, one John three, five, great Christmas verse.
He appeared to take away sins.
His advent was to take away our sin,
the darkness of sin lost to him in his life, death
and resurrection like this is what Jesus came to do.
Or think of one Corinthians 15
talking about Christ's resurrection,
how it has purchased resurrection for us.
Listen to this, I tell you this, flesh
and blood cannot inherit the kingdom of God,
nor does the perishable inherit the imperishable.
Behold, I tell you a mystery where shall not all sleep,
we shall all be changed.
In a moment, in a twinkling of an eye at the last trumpet,
that second advent, the trumpet will sound the dead will be
raised imperishable.
We shall be changed. This perishable body, the one
that we wear right now that we're dying and sick in
and all the things this perish body must put on the
imperishable, this mortal body must put on immortality.
When the perishable puts on the imperishable,
the mortal puts on immortality, then shall come
to pass the saying that is written.
Check this out. Death is swallowed up in victory.
Oh, death. Where is your victory?
Death, where is your sting?
Because the sting of death is sin.
It's going to happen because of sin.
The power of sin is the law.
But thanks be to God who gives us the victory
through our Lord Jesus Christ.
Evil sin, death lost, darkness lost
to the Messiah, to the true light.
So I don't want us to ever deny the fact
that it's dark in our world.
It is dark, evil pervades.
Sin is heavy.
Death comes regularly. It's dark.
We're walking through a very dark world.
But the light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it.
This is the light. The true light has come
and the world has lost darkness, has lost sin,
has lost evil has lost to him.
That's good news at Christmas. It's good news every day.
So as I talk about that, you know, you think, man,
everybody would wanna be a part of that, right?
Who wouldn't want to walk in light instead
of walking in darkness, kind
of feeling your way and stubbing your toe?
Like who wouldn't want to walk in this light?
Well, the reality is some people just walk around
with their eyes closed.
You saw it in first in in John one verses nine and 10.
The true light which gives light
to everyone was coming into the world.
He was in the world and the world was made through him.
Yet the world did not know him.
This word, the creator, the true light,
he was finally here.
But it says the world did not know him.
We might say it this way. The world ignored him.
The world ignored him.
Now we just read it though.
Verse nine says, the true light gives light to everyone.
So how are people still walking in darkness?
How do they still not know him
if he's given light to everyone, how?
How? This is a contradiction. Is that what this is?
They're still walking in darkness
because of the blinding effects of sin.
Romans one explains this really well.
Just listen to verses 18 to 25.
One example of it says, the wrath
of God is revealed from heaven against all ungodliness
and unrighteousness of men who by their unrighteousness,
suppress the truth.
For what can be known about God is plain to them
because God has shown it to them
for his invisible attributes, namely his eternal power.
Divine nature have been clearly perceived
ever since the creation of the world
in the things that have been made.
Meaning we can tell there's something out there.
There's a God out there.
This is who he is, kind of his character just
by looking at creation.
So they are without excuse for
although they knew God, they did not honor him as God
or give thanks to him,
but they became futile in their thinking.
Their foolish hearts were, what's the word?
Darkened, claiming to be wise.
They became fools, exchanged the glory of the immortal God
for images resembling mortal man and birds and animals
and creeping things.
That's the effect of sin.
The rest of it even talks about preferring
and supporting the works of darkness instead
of the works of God.
And all of that comes back to rejecting God as
who he is as king.
So the fact that he has given light
to everyone is why Romans one can say
that all are without excuse.
Because apart from God's intervention, every one
of us has rejected the light.
Every one of us have rejected God.
And what do we get when we reject God? We get darkness.
We get darkness now in our lives.
We get destruction now in our lives.
We get darkness forever separated from God.
Listen, I just want just a side note here.
Beware of rejecting God's commands and
and God's plan in your life.
It only leads to destruction. It only leads to darkness.
And it doesn't have to be massive big.
It can be really subtle. Small things.
Rejecting his plan, his commands for your own way,
for the world's way will lead to destruction.
So the world ignored him. The world does ignore him.
But there's an even further rejection of God here.
John in chapter one explains the way that most
of the Jews at the time of Jesus responded to this light.
Look at verse 11 again.
It says, he came to his own, meaning his own people.
His own people did not receive him.
'cause remember, Jesus was born into a Jewish family.
He was born in a Jewish area.
He was born among Jewish customs. He was raised Jewish.
He studied the Jewish scriptures. This was his people.
He was an Israelite.
Yet how did the majority of his own people respond to him?
They refused him.
The world ignored him. His own people refused him.
And this is people, listen, remember this.
These are people who knew the prophecies
from hundreds of years ago.
They knew all the answers. They knew who they were.
They they they were looking for.
And many of those prophecies had been fulfilled when
Jesus was born.
Like they had it all.
They even had expectant hearts 'cause Rome was taking over.
And they were thinking like, man,
this Messiah's gotta come right now.
Sure seems like this is the right time.
They were expectant for the Messiah, but they missed it.
They were looking for something else.
They were wanting someone else.
They were wanting someone militarily invested
to ha drive out those hated Romans.
They wanted somebody to come take back the land
and come to free them from oppression.
That's what they thought they wanted.
And when Jesus failed
to meet those expectations, what happened?
They crucified it. Now it
was God's plan for him to be crucified.
But the Jewish people were responsible
because they refused him as the Messiah that he was.
Listen, I fear that something similar is happening today.
Now we're not gonna re crucify Jesus.
We're not standing here rejecting him
and say, give us Barabbas instead of Him.
We're not doing that. But there are people
everywhere who are rejecting God for
who he is, not for who he is.
Sorry, they're rejecting God not for who he is, but
because he doesn't fulfill some unfair
or selfish expectation they have of him.
So it's not because of like just the truth of who he is.
It's that they have imposed some selfish or materialistic
or unfair expectation on God
that if you don't do this, then I'm out.
And he never said he was gonna do it.
And so we're rejecting some version of God that we think
or the problem comes
where we grow up in a Christian environment
and we culturally look the part.
We know the answers to the questions in Sunday school,
but we have no personal life-giving relationship
with God by faith.
If that was happening back then, it can still happen today.
We can look the part, we can have the answers,
but we don't know God.
So be careful. Be careful not
to merely go through the motions of Christianity.
Be careful not to put on God something that He's not
where he is never promised.
Because what John is calling us to here in verses 12
and 13 is the counter to all of that, the counter
to this fake churchianity kind of reality
or to reject God because he's something that he's not.
He never said he was, but rejecting something we've put on
him the counter to all of that, the counter to someone
who is walking in darkness to the counter, to someone
who is walking in death.
Watch this verses 12 and 13.
But to all who did receive him, not those who ignored him,
those who refuse him, to those who did receive this light,
who believed in his name, he gave the right
to become children of God who were born not of blood,
of the will of flesh, nor the will of man,
but were born of God.
Listen, here's the truth, you can receive him.
The world ignored him.
The people he was among at the time refused him.
You can receive him.
And this, this is true.
It doesn't matter how dark the path you've been
walking has been.
It. It doesn't matter how blind you feel like you've been.
The light shines in it and the darkness has not overcome it.
It doesn't matter. You look at your life like,
well, there's no way I could be saved.
No this, this is talking about light shining in darkness.
The whole point of this, this prophecy.
Listen to this one, 700 years before Jesus came
before God, the Son took on flesh.
Listen to Isaiah chapter nine verse two.
700 years earlier, the people
who walked in darkness have seen a great light.
Those who dwelt in a land of deep darkness on them has light
shone Israel.
Let's talk about them walking in
darkness for hundreds of years.
They have no hope. They're waiting for the Messiah
for his light to show up.
And he did.
Hundreds of years later he did so thank God
for that, that he did it.
But it also applies to those of us today
who are still walking in darkness,
feeling their way through a dark room.
Stubbing toes lost without hope.
How exhausting is that right?
To try to make it
through life slowly.
Tripping and hurting and falling
and destruction and darkness.
How exhausting is that
yet?
Hear me clearly today. It doesn't have to be that way.
You don't have to. In
fact, that's why God brought you here today.
That's why God put a Christian friend in your life.
Somebody in your neighborhood invited you
to their Christmas party and you showed up here today.
That's why God did that.
Acts 1727 says that they should seek God
and perhaps feel their way toward him and find him.
Yet he's actually not far from each one of us.
Why did God put that reflector of light in your life?
It's so that you would see and find God.
Listen, friend, if you've been walking spiritually,
if you've been walking in darkness, if you've been trying
to fill that hole in your heart or
or whatever you might explain that to be,
if you've been trying to fill that with pleasure
or with stuff
or with some other God that you've been seeking
and you just find yourself still in darkness
after darkness, yet right now you're sensing that
for some reason God seems to be working in your heart,
he's moving in your heart somehow.
Don't run away from that.
Don't run away from that. Because the reality is you cannot
open your own eyes.
You cannot open your own heart. You can't awaken your heart.
You cannot do any of that.
So the fact that God is,
if you feel this prompting in your spirit towards
what I've been sharing about today, that you can see Jesus,
his life, death and resurrection in your place,
you can start to see that that's starting to make sense.
Sense for your hope for today, your hope for eternity.
It's starting to click a little bit like that.
Don't deny that. That's God himself.
You didn't walk in here today like, yeah, I'm just,
I'm gonna decide to believe this Jesus
thing to no you didn't.
Right? It's God's work. He's drawing you.
He's moving in your heart. That's what verse 13 said, right?
He says, who were born not of blood
or of the will of the flesh or of the will of man,
but born of God.
There's nothing you can do to make yourself born,
to make yourself alive on your own.
You're dead spiritually, but God can make you alive.
God can give you this new birth.
It's not a physical birth, it's a spiritual birth
where he makes you
new again.
You and I can't do that. There's no sacrifice
or amount of sacrifices we could give.
There's no strong act that we could do to manufacture this.
There's no emotional desire we could have that's deep enough
or we cry hard enough.
None of that matters. Only
by God's spirit are you drawn to him
and made new spiritually.
If you sense that in your heart right now,
that's God working in you.
'cause this is not natural. It's not natural to want
to confess your sin and find hope in Christ
and something outside of yourself.
That doesn't happen naturally.
It only happens by God's spirit.
And so if you're feeling drawn by God,
you don't want to ignore that.
You don't want to refuse that.
What you want to do is receive that.
How do he say, how do you receive the gift
that he's talking about here?
Verse 12. By believing in his name,
by orienting the hope of your life
and your eternity toward all that he is
and all that he's done believing, not just agreeing,
believe like God, I'm all in.
I am yours.
I'm turning away from anything that I've believed before.
I'm turning away from the things that I turned to
before to to find life, to find light.
It didn't work. I'm turning to you as my life
and my light in everything.
'cause that's then what he promises to do
as he works in your life is he's going to lead you to
that light switch of faith so that when you walk
through your room, the light's on, it's flooded your heart
and you can actually walk in life
because then it gives confidence, humble confidence
that you can walk through the rooms of your life
because you are in the light as he is in the light.
Scripture says it's a whole
different way of seeing the world.
It's a whole different way of seeing
everything in our lives.
And you know what might be the best part of this?
What did it say God gives to those
who receive him by faith?
The right to become children of God.
Now,
Like Just think about being God's
child, right?
Just when you're hurting, when you're,
you're needy,
God of the universe looks at you
as his child like believer.
Listen that that means a whole lot.
But just think of this, you are in the royal line now.
You're a child of God,
full access to and power from God Almighty.
What a gift, right? That's Christmas.
He came as the light to do all of this for us so
that we could be children of
God.
That's what the true light brings church.
So let's rejoice like overwhelmingly rejoice in the fact
that he's made us by faith, his children,
and let's reflect that light to others so
that they might believe and become children of God as well.
So if you would pray with me towards those ends,
just as we do enter a time of prayer,
search your heart and see if this
belief is true of you.
Maybe it is for the first time you're,
you're awakening in your heart to this reality
of who he is and what he's done.
What do you do with that? Romans says, you
believe in your heart that God raised him from the dead,
that he did everything needed to save you.
And you confess with your mouth that Jesus is Lord.
You say, God, I'm in like inside your heart.
You say, God, I believe this. I am in. That's my hope.
And then you confess with your mouth,
Jesus is my Lord.
And so you run to him in your heart,
you say, God, I'm a sinner.
I cannot say myself. I can't awaken myself,
but you seem to be awakening me.
So I'm coming to you for salvation.
And then tell somebody about it.
Say, Jesus is my Lord
and Savior that'ss what Scripture says,
you will be saved.
The true light has come,
the darkness has not overcome it.
No darkness in your life can overcome that.
So run to 'em today, the light of the world.
God, thank you for being that.
Thank you for drawing us to yourself
today, every day tomorrow.
And we look forward to that second advent when you come back
and we, we see you're appearing.
God draws us. Give us belief, faith, trust more
and more today, tomorrow, the next day,
every day till you return.
Help us worship you now in spirit
and in truth in Jesus' authority.
Amen.